hello when to welcome to this video what
is wrong with a cowboy that's a really
high rating it's like a 100 point
favorite against me that's unusual
normally I'm the favorite in all matches
let's see what happens here yeah plays
into a goof algae and kale oh I don't
quite know how this is plate I think
this is a known on line dude this is
also done just to get them a bit more
tension into the position with 92 I can
always just take care play you six and
be completely I mean be super solid the
Greenfeld fianchetto here with c65 some
very very sound is taking moment down
now we still take them as I mentioned
this is extremely solid hmm well now I
can go before i'm not i'm not sure if it
is really great but that's at least a
bit more interesting so let's go there I
wonder about 96 indisposition my
intended with sly probably doesn't work
maybe I wanted to play see 594 and then
be five giving up a pawn that
a bit skeptical no it doesn't go for
that he plays 45 immediately okay that's
not a big deal you five I can always
take 187 okay so
[Music]
chat probably from the equal I wonder if
c5 is this is a bit more interesting i'm
not sure if it's really good but it's a
bit more interesting if I was coming ok
stop is higher for the time being I mean
he can't play f6 and be really really
persistent with this idea ok so III is
Sam is week three this week
yeah they are probably actually taken on
d5 that it looks like like us really
just fine yeah simple but good
try to reposition the bishop on to
everyone maybe I have some idea to push
the dish of the night back okay doesn't
look very effective Black has to watch
out a little bit for is a pawn it's
still wonder if f 6m f65 isn't good cute
of to support that or just completely
shuts everything down it should be ok I
mean let the night has no squares really
first start to check it
you have ideas I know it sounds very
simple it the should be one and then
take a phone what's he doing against it
don't see anything it's pretty pretty
awful okay so really
I have to do anyway
so I go to g5 and bring the King around
I don't see how he defends this oh it's
interesting with g6 was just going to
get lost
and there's a porn star the Kings you
three this night c4 yeah it's still not
such a huge thing i think i have before
here take taking you for this is not
good enough taken to a five no but i
can't do this
he takes nc6 is the issue
time 188 patient should do the trick
check too many balls check blahnik
resigns all right he spoiled a really
good position out of the economy I think
roughly here Black is very comfortable
yeah I also expected him to play this my
idea was to play this but I think it
doesn't work I think he can take of
course I don't have to play beehive
straight away but I mean this is going
to be very comfortable for black
heretonight them now ok anyway this is
not bad of course but I thinking here's
it's some all went wrong for him I'm
surprised that the engine actually
thinks I'm better taken cream on here
maybe maybe that night isn't all that
good I mean this was this this I was
very surprised about because I didn't
see the upside yeah I don't want to play
you for you anyway oiling I cannot play
it anyway and now I mean I had a clear
plan but he simply who never addressed
it may be there was no real way to
address it this just seems lost I mean
that's what the engine suggests so and
now h 0 instead of this but i don't
really see the big difference if i do
the same thing other than 93 works oh my
god now it's a bit computer rich but
yeah that's our divorce
under fire that's the difference after
Bishop f8 there is no count to play what
salmon and this is ending its lost I
think Oh bishop h4 I didn't didn't think
of this I don't have a good square
simply it's just tactics I don't have a
good square so okay i don't know like he
really takes in check huh interesting
right the TF this this should win my
visual Jake's ourselves love it I think
M should be reasonably clean okay right
now I just too many points you cannot
stop order something like here on to
those two split pawns will promote like
a son has no condoms I'm ok guys thanks
for watching